cas d'accident si vous suivez toute la
procédure il faudrait que vous montre
allumiez l'éclairage pilotés à distance
les infrastructures routières
l'éclairage urbain une installation
actuellement en cours dans la communauté
urbaine du grand dijon développé par
bouygues des innovations au coeur d'une
visite des sénateurs yvelinois j'avais
envie de faire connaître encore mieux à
mes collègues de son entreprise de ce
territoire de co et bouygues
d'une part parce que ce sont des
entreprises familiales ensuite c'est
sont android qui rayonne dans le monde
entier à travers ses entreprises
on a des exemples importants sur le
développement économique des impôts
mentant sur la mobilité sur la
transition environnementale
quand je pense que c'était deux exemples
importants un virage vers les smart city
ni pallier le manque de médecins avec la
télémédecine des avancées technologiques
destinés notamment aux collectivités
l'origine c'est la volonté des
collectivités territoriales cette
volonté elle rencontre à savoir faire
d'une très grande entreprise qui en plus
est française et qui comprend les
collectivités territoriales parce que
que ce soit dans le domaine de la
construction ou de l'aménagement du
territoire à la cette expérience avec
les collectivités territoriales
ceux là ont rejoint un texte que nous
allons sans doute examiner ou en octobre
puis au printemps la loi notre adopté
définitivement le 7 août 2015 doit faire
l'objet d'un travail parlementaire
une réforme sur les collectivités
territoriales voulue dans le
gouvernement